have you ever thought about starting a
tick tock no no i'm already burnt out
with all this [ __ ]
yeah i can't do tick tock i respect for
people who like start tick tocks now
and do content creation and all that
[ __ ] on the side it's like i barely have
enough time to [ __ ] upload on my main
channel yeah as
like as a kid i thought like oh you know
old people parents they just don't know
how to use the new technology new social
media
and like as i've grown older i've
realized that's not the case at all it's
just
we just don't have the time to get into
them or learn
learn how they work and that's just
that's just the end or be all like your
parents could probably
use everything you use um they just
don't have the time or energy to get
into something new and they just rather
stick with something comfortable right i
think i did open tik tok one time and i
was gonna make a video on it
um like actually using it and i got like
five minutes in and i was like what the
[ __ ] is this editing
thing i was like i was so confused i was
like i don't like this i don't i'm not
used to this i'm scared of this yeah
maybe that's how boomers feel yeah yeah
yeah yeah i was like oh what is this
unfamiliar territory delete i mean i'm
sure i could have learned it if i spared
the time but i was like oh [ __ ]
is it worth that because like it took me
long took me this long to just learn
[ __ ] youtube and twitter
and that that's like i i feel tic tocs
adding like
so many extra layers which i appreciate
when there's a good tick tock meme
because
like a lot of tick tock i've seen is
[ __ ] but like when you see a good tick
tock mean there's
nothing that compares to the [ __ ]
levels of
i can't even explain it there's so many
levels of just meme and internet culture
like condensed into such a short period
of time i've probably seen some of the
funniest [ __ ] come from
oh yeah yeah there was this one thing i
don't know if you saw it it was about
this guy
was uh doing a tick tock with his like
he was like introducing his girlfriend
the star wars oh yeah so today is my
birthday and i'm gonna introduce to you
my girlfriend
and then it's literally like the whole
hostage situation yeah it's so
good just like an extra layer just keeps
getting added
every every time and it just goes so far
beyond what you thought it would
that i just think it was [ __ ] genius
when tick tock's like that i [ __ ]
love tiktok yeah
um everything else i'm an absolute
boomer when it comes to tick tock
because what is what i will say is that
like content
the content algorithm tick tock seems to
be so far beyond
other platforms where it's so easy to
find content that suits your tastes
um whereas i don't know with youtube now
it's just
it's youtube seems to be going through a
transition period where he doesn't
really know what it wants to recommend
you should recommend you shorts or long
videos it doesn't know anymore because
the internet is kind of switching around
because youtube's just trying to compete
with literally every other social media
out there yeah yeah so like when they
added like the whole like instagram
stories replica as well i don't even
know what that was those were [ __ ]
called
yeah like they were like there was that
and then the community post is literally
just twitter
remember when stories were just snapchat
and then instagram had stories and then
twitter had stories and then
youtube has stories and that everything
has stopped everything has stories
i hate the stories on on twitter i hate
the fleets
i [ __ ] think that they're so garbage
i used it once and i was like
all right i hate it i never use them i
never look at my friends ones i never
post any i'm just like get that [ __ ] out
of here yeah
it's taking up real estate on my app
it's like another [ __ ] post i could be
seeing like
yeah it's that amount of space that's
covered up by fleece i feel like do i
really need my tweets to delete like i'm
not really that like into it like i
don't i don't think they need to be
deleted like that's
just save it i already have like old
tweets delete automatically from my
thing anyways
yeah yeah it makes it completely
obsolete who wants them to be deleted in
24 apps because no one's looking at it
anyway if it was a tweet that got
deleted in 24 hours i could kind of
understand
what that would be useful for like if
i'm posting i'm going live on my twitch
yeah i haven't deleted in six hours yeah
that makes sense but
if wide is in a completely different
section i don't wanna like i don't know
yeah have you have you seen that uh have
you seen the twitter live streams as
well
well yeah and then also twitter just
copied clubhouse with the
uh well essentially the whole app and
just put it in twitter which i think it
actually suits more
but i don't i don't know is that what
that is because i keep getting
notifications
of like uh certain artists i followed
being like starting a space yeah they
started a space yeah
yeah i'm pretty sure it's just yeah i
think it's kind of just i don't know
i don't know i hate it because i i
didn't know what it was and like
some some some people who i like i'm a
big lurker online right and some people
who i was following started like this
you know space thing
i joined it and it was like google has
joined the room i was like [ __ ]
get that snow they don't need to know i
hate that yeah
no working for you i just i don't know
if i'm if i'm the boomer here when i
just don't like some of the new features
they add i can't figure out
i'm just being unreceptive to the new
thing or it's actually terrible like i
i don't know anymore yeah because
sometimes if things
is it me that change or is it mature it
turns out to be really good and i like
it
but then it's just not integrated well
enough in the start and i'm not really
into it because i remember i was like
that with the instagram stories as well
when i first started i was like what is
this
deletes in 24 hours yeah what the [ __ ]
the point of this and now i'm just like
all right finna upload to my story let's
go now i think stories are better than
posts
yeah now these stories are great but i i
yeah maybe i don't know maybe we should
[ __ ] boom i don't know yeah whatever
pro it's probably the boomer
kind of probably a boomer it's probably
a 24 year old boomer thing yeah yeah
what can i say